Most simply, conditional wait variables allow you to take one thread
off the scheduling que until there is a signal from another
thread, that it should be put back on. This is useful
if we don't want one thread to continue it's work until
the work of another thread is finished. To give an example,
let's oppose that we have a thread A over here, and
a thread B over here. Thread B wants to stop until
thread A's work is done. Now to use a conditional weight variable,
we need three things. A variable indicating whether the
work is done, or some other condition that can be
tested in memory. A lock that we can apply to
this variable... And a special conditional wait variable. Now after
finishing the work, thread A is going to acquire the
lock, change is_done to true and then send a signal
to anyone waiting on this condition, a signal that they
should wake up, and then he'll unlock the lock. Thread
B, for his part, will first acquire the lock, and
then check if the work is done. If it isn't,
he will wait. Now, it's important that this cond-wait not
only makes thread B wait, but it also unlocks a mutex.
This will allow thread A to acquire the lock and
eventually send the signal. The call blocks until the signal
is received and thread B acquires the lock again. Hence
the need to unlock it at the end of the code.
At first this might seem unnecessarily complicated. Why do we need
this if statement, before the cond_wait procedure call, for instance? Well,
if it weren't there, then it's possible that the signal will
have already come, and we would never see it. So it's important
to check that there's something to wait for, before you actually
wait. Given that there is such a condition to check We better
also have a lock for it. Otherwise we might decide that
we need to wait. But before we actually execute the wait function,
the signal might come. And of course, the
cond-wait method had better unlock the mutex. Otherwise
thread A would never be able to acquire
and change the condition that we're waiting on.